so we were talking in a previous video
about hypertension and the damage that
it causes on the body
and what i'd like to do is pick up
where we left off and finish that
conversation and we had kind of divided
things up into receiving
high blood pressures
and
generating high blood pressures and
receiving high pressure really that
means the vessels right that's where the
pressure is going to be seen
and so the vessels can get damaged and
we talked about some of the different
ways that that can happen
and in fact there are the
larger arteries and also the smaller
arteries
but now let's focus our attention on
generating
high pressures because this might be
less intuitive but actually
making the pressure go so high is not an
easy thing to do and it's actually a
very challenging task for the heart to
accomplish and
and in trying to figure it out sometimes
the heart can run into troubles
so
there was an equation and that equation
was delta p equals q times r and i
thought we'd put some words to this
equation
so the idea that delta p that's
basically saying the arterial pressure
minus the venous pressure so if you have
blood and it's exiting here
that's got a certain pressure on it and
as it enters again on the other side
into the atrium it's got a pressure on
the venous side
so we're saying that the pressure
leaving in the arteries minus the
pressure returning in the veins
is what's going to help you
take a certain flow of blood
q
past the resistance in the vessels
so that's a way of thinking about it and
specifically let me actually draw out
some of this resistance you have of
course resistance once it gets into the
arteries and so you've got some r
resistance there and then you've got
more resistance once you get into the
arterioles and in fact i'm going to
triple underline that one because
there's lots of resistance in the
arterioles
and then you've got resistance in the
capillaries and you've got resistance in
the
veins and then you've got the blood
returning
into the
venous side so there's resistance in the
circulatory system and there's a flow of
blood that you're actually trying to
move around right
so anything anything at all that
increases the resistance or increases
the flow
is going to force the amount of pressure
you have to put in on the arterial side
to go up
and
now if i draw it out you'll see even
more clearly why this is a this is a
problem so
if you have let's say the left ventricle
and i'll leave a little space for the
valves
and this is the the chamber of the heart
that's doing the pumping now
and it's pumping the blood out into the
aorta so this is the aorta
and this is another valve and this valve
is called the aortic valve
pretty easy to remember name aortic
valve and it separates the aorta from
the left ventricle
lv for left ventricle
so the left ventricle is basically going
to have to try to get blood through this
door
through this valve
and the way to do that is to apply a
force to that blood
and force it through that door now the
aortic valve has a certain area
and so if you remember
anytime you have a force over an area
i'll write that over here
anytime you have a force over an area
you have a pressure and in this case
that is the arterial pressure so when i
talk about arterial pressure i'm
actually talking about the force that
the left ventricle generates
on that aortic valve that area of the
aortic valve
so
now think about it if you have let's say
more resistance let's say there's lots
and lots of resistance in the vessels so
that all these numbers are
slowly going up up up well that's going
to cause
the overall resistance to go up and now
the left ventricle has to put more force
or you could say what if you have larger
flow you actually have a larger volume
of blood you're trying to move around
again the
aortic pressure is going to have to go
up so the way that the left ventricle
accomplishes this or tries to accomplish
this is is is by basically building more
muscle
so this is one strategy it'll say okay
well if i need to generate more force
why not generate more muscle so this
becomes very muscular in here if you
actually
look at a heart that has had
high pressures over the years oftentimes
you have what's called left
ventricular hypertrophy
so on the surface it sounds great right
left ventricular hypertrophy sounds like
you're making the muscle of the heart
stronger and that sounds like a good
thing you know that's certainly why
uh i go to the gym i want my muscles to
get bigger so
uh
it's confusing then to to hear that
that's not a good thing and here's why
so now imagine you have all this muscle
and you're you're feeling really good
but then i tell you that well this
muscle is using more oxygen so it's
using more oxygen but you notice i
didn't draw any new blood vessels yet so
there are no new blood vessels getting
oxygen to this muscle
but the muscle is definitely using a lot
of
energy and it needs you know a lot of
oxygen and so what happens is that you
have areas
where
blood is basically able to get to those
areas
and other areas where blood is not able
to get there and where the blood is
unable to get enough oxygen to that
heart muscle you could have a heart
attack or a myocardial infarction
so left ventricular hypertrophy is a way
of
compensating for needing more force
but it comes with a little bit of a
a risk because now
you might have
a risk
of
an mi or myocardial infarction
the other possibility is that the left
heart doesn't compensate
and you have what what's called left
heart failure
and
what that basically means is that the
left heart says you know what i can't
generate the pressures that are being
required to move all that blood around
and so i won't i won't generate those
pressures i'll i'll do the best i can
and maybe i can't move let's say six
liters of blood
around the body but i can do five liters
or five and a half liters so it'll try
to do what it can to move as much blood
as possible but it is essentially not
compensating completely
and that's why you sometimes see people
with heart failure
after having years and years of high
blood pressure their heart simply can't
keep up
and so you you experience heart failure